a partir de este sábado 20 millones de
franceses ya no podrán ir al cine al
teatro ni a los restaurantes después de
las nueve de la noche con el
resurgimiento de la epidemia de
coronavirus en francia el presidente
manuel marco anunció un toque de queda
desde las nueve de la noche hasta las
seis de la mañana durante al menos
cuatro semanas
personalmente trabajo desde casa así que
confieso que las salidas eran mi única
alegría en la vida suave mismo del
césped ya además de parís y su región se
trata de ocho ciudades importantes es
decir casi un tercio de la población es
la primera vez que una proporción tan
grande de habitantes está bajo toque de
queda desde la segunda guerra mundial yo
lo veo un poco injusto porque por un
lado egoístamente nos decimos a nosotros
mismos que no somos nosotros los que
estamos en peligro
y pasando todo llamó pongamos yo también
estoy encantado de pasar un tiempo en
casa en primer lugar por mi trabajo pero
no me gusta que me digan qué hacer
el presidente francés también anunció
ayudas adicionales para los sectores
económicos más golpeados por el toque de
queda y que se van a ver aún más
afectados como el sector de los
restaurantes puntos común
7 30pm va a ser la última toma de pedido
como aquí la gente no come a las 7 va a
ser un poco difícil para las medidas
fueran criticadas por algunos
representantes locales electos pero la
alcaldesa de parís respaldo por su parte
la decisión del presidente prometiendo
apoyo al mundo de la cultura en la
capital